i say hello to my in-studio guest to
kick off hour number three never met uh
you sir but a pleasure to have you here
in person for the first time quarterback
of the pittsburgh steelers mason rudolph
good to see you here on the program
thanks rich thanks good to see you here
man
so um what's going on in your world what
are you doing much um
do you live out here in the off season
i'll spend some time out here training
uh down in newport beach and uh okay
you know there's not a bad place to
be this time of year at all uh back and
forth from pitt so yeah trying to get
better trying to fine-tune some things
okay fundamental wise all right yeah how
do you do that in the middle of march
like what are you like throwing just
just uh working on you know things like
arm slot throwing on the run nuance
things okay um i think you don't have a
lot of time during the season to always
work on the fundamentals your game plan
and then your and you're watching film
and so i like this time of year to kind
of you know pay more attention to those
things how much better better would you
be if you get every rep
every rep everywhere i think maybe it's
just experience is the biggest teacher
right so um i got a lot of practice reps
this year actually
um
he sometimes he practice half thursday
you know friday sometimes so i'd have
the wednesday thursday reps to you know
keep myself sharp right in case you know
i needed to be sharp well i don't want
to i don't want to put i i feel like i
might have just put you on the spot a
little bit right put me on the spot i
know that's okay no it's all right it's
all right because you know i don't want
to you know
have you come across it saying that you
you deserved more reps or anything like
that no no no you just asked me so i
said the reps are great
who wouldn't want reps okay yeah i i
will take the reps i would look i would
be much better doing like we had uh trey
lance on uh the week of the super bowl
okay and he's just like yeah if i had
more reps i'd be better yeah and people
are saying you're not he might not be
that guy so what do you
think your status is for the steelers as
you and i are sitting here right now my
status is uh
you know finally having the ability to
compete to be the starting quarterback
so um i'm excited about that you know i
uh
i think there's a lot to be excited
about the pieces around us um you know
we've added some
bolstered the o-line okay got a couple
of great young receivers
um you know a young running back who's
workhorse so a lot to be excited what's
your relationship with tomlin like
great he's uh he's
he's had my back you know for a long
time and and uh we have a lot of
informal conversations that are fun he's
he's a
master of psychology what do you mean
he
he's got
relationships we've all been on teams
where coaches are ceos and they kind of
hang back in the shadows and he does a
great job of
connecting
to me he's asking you hey how's your
brother doing uh you know mason
hollywood how's the house how's his
acting so he he's just
uh
master psychology as i said and and very
personal with his players okay so he
kind of messes with your head a little
bit
no no well well we both give each other
crap well how do you how do you give
mike tomlin crap
well he'll he'll uh
you know he'll talk about uh on those
days where i would get the reps
wednesday thursday um
you know let's go rudolph this is your
day you know this is this is your this
is ben will always wear a a ball cap and
practice uh and he'll go through
individual period with just a with just
a hat on instead of the helmet
and so
that's just what we did we all started
wearing ball caps you know when i got
here
older guys quarterbacks and and um so
i'll i'll mess with them put the ball
cap on just for a little bit but i'll
put the helmet on quickly and you'll say
oh you got you got your ball cap on
today rudolph you think it's your day
mm-hmm so
that's your way of messing yeah we just
it's we've got a great relationship okay
that's cool so your brother's an actor i
don't know yes he's uh he
played college football clemson actually
and and uh has been out here in
hollywood for about a year now what's he
doing
uh he did he did a movie with a lifetime
he did a lifetime movie about six months
ago this fall and he did a lifetime
movie he did can you imdb his uh sure
what's his what's your brother's name
logan rudolph logan yeah rudolph yeah
see give me give me his because you know
i've i've played various roles
yeah uh as male reporter in a csi miami
um what'd you say he's got a great head
shot i mean yeah killer rivalry was that
the name yeah that's that's the one
there you go it's in post-production it
hasn't come out yet
it sounds like a a lifetime like a
lifetime movie like somebody's that
they're going at each other and yeah you
want the description here yes please all
right here we go give me the uh charlie
and annika are volleyball rivals from
opposing teams volleyball so it's a
killer as a shot there you go
not like every year the two teams pull
pranks on each other but things start to
get out of hand when annika's volleyball
partner is found dead oh no is that
logan i think he gets i think he gets
set up for the murder is he oh oh i see
but he's not like out right on page five
he's framed yeah no no he's not the one
who goes he's not the murderer now no
he's not the victim i'm saying he's he's
not the best we can't have eight no he
stays alive okay we can't have him out
in five minutes no we can't that
wouldn't be good
okay great yeah this is great all right
we'll take a look at that
fantastic see now we're promoting your
brother here on the program appreciate
it okay
[Laughter]
you got it makes us
no no it's okay it's all good so uh all
right uh i we we play a game here called
start bench cut mason okay
um where we give you three options you
have to start one you have to bench when
you have to cut one right okay it's sort
of like that you know what mary kill yes
game okay you pretty much got that
familiar you're familiar with that from
your old oklahoma state days and things
like that okay very good all right here
we go uh mike do you have the ability to
play this
because i want to show mason we like uh
the lifetime movie his brother was gonna
have uh
killer production value okay go ahead
and hit it right
start drop down
sit down and be quiet
okay here we go uh mason rudolph first
up
best football hair
okay
here we go start bench cut i'll give you
three probably mike gundy
troy polamalu
kevin green
yeah kept two stealer halls fame legends
and then of course the man who is no
longer 40. what is he 50 something he's
in his 50s okay mike gundy your former
college coach now the mullet well mike
gundy never had a head and shoulders
commercial okay so i gotta go troy
you're gonna start him start troy
i mean
my gun is a great friend of mine and
lifelong branded mentor so yes
um but i'm probably gonna get in trouble
with the steeler community if i go home
you have to go home yes yeah i'd say uh
i'd say we'll uh
we'll you know we'll we'll we'll binge
mike okay and we'll cut kg oh my gosh
you can't even cut his own coach
so gundy you and gundy you're still
tight we are you know how often do you
guys talk hug off
you know he's very busy during the
season we'll check in with each other
you know every once in a couple weeks
okay so um he's uh yeah i had a
anytime you have a coach who was the
alma mal you know played it as alma
mater and played quarterback sure i
think it was very valuable where does
his molly come from
uh where'd that mullet come where did
his mullet come from where did he come
from one day he came into practice and
had it and uh
kept it
did you never say anything to him i did
i i liked it i mean i i uh
my nickname from his big daddy
so i'd say big daddy is i think it's
time maybe we get a little trim yes
and uh he listened i mean he eventually
cut he trimmed it i think he had it my
my senior year only okay i don't know
i'm not sure but either one or two years
but he trimmed it eventually cause after
i left
it all right yeah all right next one uh
next one here's another one for for
mason rudolph stark bench cut best
pittsburgh cuisine
pepe's number seven which is the
rothless burger
uh pramanti steak sandwich or uh
allegheny's
uh
sandwich shop roast beef what do you got
for me yeah i gotta get a bench cut
start primanti's that's a pittsburgh
staple of course love it big time
favorite okay uh pepes pepes rather yeah
a bench and then we'll cut allegheny
you're going to cut okay you're going to
bench the robles burger have you ever
had the roethlis burger i have not had
it but i've been to pepe's okay
it's great okay so i need to i need to
have the raffles burger or something do
you really or you're just saying that no
i'm i'm just saying that
no i i it's ben ever do you know if ben
has been ever had a roethlisberger i'm
sure he has i don't know that for a fact
but i would
wouldn't you have a sandwich it was
named after you you know what i would
not if it was not what i'd like
you know what i'm saying like they'd
have to aim
you want input on what the sandwich is
damn straight yeah of course what would
the eisen sandwich be yeah oh boy yeah
what would that what would be the eisen
sandwich it would have to be some sort
of an italian concoction it would have
to have some red sauce
yeah
man i have to have meatballs a chicken
parm with maybe some meatballs on top
yeah a beef chicken situation of course
breaded uh we have the bread
uh so it's multi-breaded
multi-layers of the bread a lot of
gluten a lot of gluten oh i mean look at
me a lot of inflammation please yeah
that's my problem yeah i'm too inflamed
what's what's the rudolph well
menu at pramanti
yeah give me that yeah
this walking boot is left town and now
it's it's the rudolph sandwich come on
let's go uh what do we got you know i'd
say probably uh
uh
come on probably probably like a like a
cheesesteak i'm not gonna say philly
cheesesteak you can't handle can soap
a pittsburgh cheesesteak what does that
sound like
so what is it like a beef there's a beer
shredded beef okay peppers into some
onions okay
um
maybe some tomatoes okay so we'll we'll
we'll throw a little health in there
okay with the meat
and uh we'll throw some red sauce in
there too okay
what do we call it a mason burger or
what is it a rudolph burger
no it's the whisper it's the pittsburgh
cheesesteak okay the pittsburgh
cheesecake
favorite crown
start bench cut crown jewels of england
crown royal whiskey
or the crown of your own helmet mason
rudolph um do you start bench or cut one
well you know what i'm cutting
and we are cutting the helmet as we
said
yes yeah that was good
you even approved that one you go to the
cap
[Laughter]
just wanted to throw that one out there
great start
bench right so now you came out of the
um
uh the green room and you heard my
conversation with christian kirk and
howard number two about instagram
aesthetics
because he was saying that he's all
about the aesthetics of his instagram i
don't understand what buzzword right
well because my son uses it all the time
he's like he said that's so aesthetic
this is aesthetic and what have you dude
what is it i don't understand
that definition just pleasing to the eye
okay anything that may be pleasing to
the eye but
it's my photographs i mean like how does
one you know i think you're pleasing to
the i checked out your profile
you were you had some gq material in
there do i you had some suit pictures
that you were you know yeah you look
sharp okay thank you that's why i asked
you what you know what what what
designer you wear okay thank you so you
look like a tom ford guy no
um actually if now that you've asked
yeah uh brunello cuccinelli oh wow okay
what about you because i see because you
should you're you're you're i see you're
instagrammed because i because i knew
that you were to be busting my balls
about mine yeah so i looked at yours and
you've got it's a lot of you coming off
of the plane with your goodwill bag you
know and
what is it goodwill what does that mean
what do you mean the the the goodwill
store where you go and you buy old
you look outfitted oh rich you're too
kind i'd say i mean this this one if you
just want to go to mason's page it's uh
rudolph too mason the fifth one down you
look like james bond like i'm not gonna
lie the black suit
and the white shirt
whatever foot bag is that is that a
gucci or louis van gaal
it's a louis bag and then and then i
usually i have some suit that suits
zania i try to stay in his zone oh
you're zenya oh look at that man i mean
it's looking sharp
yeah and and
let's let's get rid of that let's pull
up a glitch let's pull up one of those
ridges no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no
you're in the seat right now
it's a nice flex that you're not also
going through security there that looks
like a nice fbo yeah out there that's
how you travel i'm sure
straight out of it you're straight on
the pj yeah
you step off the step off the thing and
right into the suburban that's me his
feet never touch the ground
that's me no i don't do i don't do
play-by-play i'm a studio uh
different different different whole way
of traveling now in the nfl yeah but not
that very nice so xenia okay let's get
and what do you what do you got on today
what are you wearing today we got today
together well thank you welcome
yeah some some zany items and some some
jeans okay nothing nothing too crazy i
love it i didn't i didn't want it
i wanted to be relatively casual for you
he's like you can feel the heat from the
cheeks over here like he's very like
uncomfortable talking about that
you feel the heat from the cheeks
it's tough to it's tough to stay humble
when you're stumping when you're
stunting on the recharging show right no
mason the more you mention them you know
that that's the more packages that come
to the crib in a few days you know oh
yeah there you go some free pub you know
by the way was it what restaurant is
that the one we think is altius
my man's from pittsburgh and uh we were
talking about a restaurant earlier and
and uh altius
great spot well he's
here he goes mason here he goes no he's
he's not i mean he's from altoona
you know what i mean well he told me
pittsburgh well yeah
yeah i was born and raised in altoona i
grew up in pittsburgh as i like to say
and then i moved to l.a what do you what
do you say i like to say what does that
mean as you'd like to say well like i've
said it before okay so do you
he he says he's from the east coast do
you consider pittsburgh in east coast
town
it's from the east
i mean you like a guy from south
carolina who went to the heartland of
this country before starring in
pittsburgh pa yeah it's the east coast
making it good it's east coast time zone
and see it's okay eastern time zones
okay all right
all right so i don't know what we've
accomplished with my instagram account
other than the fact that i need to be
more aesthetic i don't know what that
means it's my life if it's not aesthetic
you know i mean yeah
okay you only get one of them okay so
mason be honest nobody is taking down
any of your oklahoma state records for a
long time right
oh i don't know well the kid there that
uh spencer's he's done a good job so he
he i think he's got another year so he
may be you know i don't know we'll see
but uh yeah you've doubled them up in
passing yards i mean no don't be humble
here bro like
thousand six hundred career yards you're
the 4400 clear of brandon whedon and 92
career touchdowns right yeah whedon had
to kind of had the two years because he
played baseball yeah that's right right
so then he came out he's also what he's
35 when he graduated right
yeah
i think thanks for coming in man i
appreciate it hope you enjoyed the
experience yeah it's great okay thank
you very good good luck to you and uh
and you're competing in latrobe right
thank you okay yeah and forward sorry is
that what they've told you you're
competing for this job yes that's that's
what they've told me and that's that's
the way i'm going to approach it
okay thanks mason rudolph
congratulations on everything going on
and you being as aesthetic as you are in
person as you are in your energy
you are the you are the epitome of i
appreciate that thank you sir greatly
appreciate that that is mason rudolph
here on the rich eisenhower hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here